to a breakthrough real-life success for
Shark Tank in a first for the ABC hit
show one couples app invention has been
acquired by a public company a
multi-million dollar deal Wow ABC's
Rebecca Jarvis has a story next into the
tank is a couple with an affordable
solution for all those digital photos
stacking up on our smartphones they are
the husband and white team that jumped
into the shark tank and not only lived
to tell about it but came away with a
deal that changed their lives and made
Shark Tank history billions of photos
are taken every day from smartphones who
doesn't have a phone with hundreds if
not thousands of photos it's extremely
intense when you're in the shark tank
you have five extremely sharp people
thank you trying to get to the bottom
line of why they want to give you money
Brian and Julie Whiteman's app lets
subscribers upload 100 photos a month
for $2.99
oh and they get a bound book in the mail
with their photos the groovebook mr.
wonderful kevin o'leary do a good thing
when he saw it I'm a photographer and
I'm passionate about it and I love the
idea of what they were doing a deal was
struck and in nine short months
staggering growth more than 1 million
people have downloaded the groovebook
app more than 200 million photos have
been uploaded and subscriptions have
grown 1,400 percent but that's not all
Shutterfly CEO and president Jeffrey
house involed took notice I was pretty
impressed with their presentation and
also their business idea and in a shark
tank first a mammoth acquisition
publicly traded Shutterfly acquiring
group booked for 14 and a half million
dollars since airing on shark tank we
could have never imagined how it would
have doubled tripled and multiplied it's
been incredible proving to all you
dreamers that a little idea can turn
into millions all it takes is hard work
a little luck and the right shark and
I'm here now is shark kevin O'Leary I
guess I should say congratulations you
saw this one early yeah thank you I was
very passionate about it because I loved
photography but I loved what the product
did it captured your life that chronic
alized it sent it to you in a book every
month so simple for $2.99 America loved
it they saw it on Shark Tank and Julie
and Brian
our multi-millionaires but even you
couldn't predicted this kind of breakout
success no we had no idea this was going
to happen but it's shown its taught all
of us what a platform shark tank is I'd
have to argue today it's the most
extensible successful venture capital
firm on earth we've got the audience we
have unlimited capital and we have
fantastic ideas like group book coming
on everyone it just brings in more and
more great ideas every week it's amazing
what happens we're just thrilled to
death so is it sad for you when when it
finally sells out okay oh like this
Shutterfly's the right home for this
product Georgian there's no question
about it this is going to grow much
bigger within the context of all the
other products
Shutterfly has my biggest job as a shark
is to make the investment initially help
mentor them during the execution process
and then I really add value I think is
every shark does at the end helping to
make their deal this young family is
just proven the American Dream is still
alive that's a great great story Kevin
thanks for coming in later this week
shark tanks are going to head going head
to head to make the most money to see
who can make the most money live right
here on GMA